one time I was about 10 my Dad pulled a
gun on my mom what and was holding it to
her head in front of you guys yeah oh
yeah
yeah I couldn't wait till we went to
sleep
he needed the audience
so um I was terrified I hate pulled a
[__] handgun and put it to your mom's
head tear I was oh I was so scared I
slipped out the back ran over to a
neighbor's call 9-1-1 God cops came and
uh I don't know why I don't I did I
wasn't there for the interaction with
them the cop but the cops left after
just a couple minutes oh I got in
trouble for going over and calling 9-1-1
are you serious yeah oh I got my ass
beat for calling 9-1-1 by your dad yeah
and my mom was mad at me yeah and I
remember getting in trouble Chelsea I
told you you only do that when shit's
serious that's 9-1-1 girl I thought it
was serious